[Musik]
österreichs größte open air
sportveranstaltung findet dieses jahr
bei strahlendem sonnenschein im wiener
prater statt
auch österreichs top vier satelliten
daten im zuge der veranstaltung geehrt
den sport hat immer noch einen sehr
hohen stellenwert beim heer der
bundesheer und leistungsbereitschaft
sind natürlich nahe liege mit begrenzt
wird also gesagt dass sport die meinen
stellenwert in der österreichischen
bundesheer vertreten als wichtig für die
fitness aller soldaten kader
untergruppen und die leistungssportler
sind die großen vorbilder
mit dem so genannten hielt sports award
waren sportler in den kategorien trainer
newcomer mannschaft behinderten sportler
und sportlerinnen und sportler des
jahres ausgezeichnet
letzter geht des klägers tools für jakob
schubert gleich zwei heute gegen
abnahmen dürfen ag für meinen trainer
ist hat er schon
dollar geschätzt wird seine fritzl tippt
übrigens auch trainieren die man einfach
glauben
der japaner viel spaß haben und immer
motiviert trainieren
die veranstaltung bietet vor allem sport
interessierten die möglichkeit sich
hautnah mit unseren heimischen sport
stars auszutauschen und das internet
schon groß zu sein ja zu lassen ist sehr
groß ist und haben sehr viele autogramme
geben leute gehen vor bei dem er ist
dort stellen und schauen noch nach und
klagen
ich glaube schon dass es
bisher können die meinen sport gar nicht
ausüben wenn man zu kleine sportarten
ist
nur ganz wenige sportler gewinnen dann
super was ich damit machen
[Musik]
[Applaus]